- Cher once told me "If it
doesn't matter in five years,
"it doesn't matter."
And I was like
- Thank you Cher.
- Truer words.
- God, I wish Cher had told me something.
Swapping.
No, that's a terrible answer.
- Well.
- Is it?
- It might not be the key,
but it definitely helps.
I think learning how to fight.
For real!
Not like spar.
Because I think humans disagree a lot.
It's going to happen.
You can't, there's no
way to get around it.
But if you learn how to
have healthy arguments,
I think it's the best
thing for a marriage.
- My trick is I married someone
eight billion times nicer
and kinder and more patient
and then some reason he puts up with me
and it's worked out well.
- In truth, I became much more
comfortable as I grew older
and as you let go your desire
to compare yourself to
everything and everyone.
- You realize how unreasonable that is.
- We are given, once you
can really understand
we are given an unrealistic
and unobtainable idea
and representation of beauty,
you go "oh wait a minute!
"The whole thing's just
a joke and a trick?
"Oh then who cares?"
- The worrying about what
other people think of you
I think becomes so, so unimportant.
- Also when you fill your
life with wonderful things
and friends and love, you don't have time.
You just don't have time
to worry about nonsense.
Find what makes you unique.
Because if you can be unique
and be yourself,you are irreplaceable.
But the minute you start to fall in line,
you're a dime a dozen.
- I remember when I was
never getting hired,
which was good 20 or 22 years,
and I thought maybe
I'll go into production
and I'll stop the acting side of it
and I'll do this and I remember my mom
which I thought she was
going to be thrilled
with that much more stable
and she said "When are you going to
"get back to doing what you do?"
Doesn't matter if you're hired.
Doesn't matter what the outcome is.
You need to do what it is you do.
So just kind of stay the course.
- Is it really lame if I say my husband?
I mean, let's start first of
all, I have Stockholm syndrome.
Let's start there.
Okay, he captured me
about eight years ago.
- It's true guys.
- He has done a great
job of brainwashing me
and I'm telling you, I am in.
Okay?
No, I'm a big fan of my husband.
He's funny, he's kind,
he's committed to me
and our daughters and a
thousand other wonderful things.
And he just makes me smile.
- Now I have to say
Ben too, but I mean it.
He's my face, my best
friend, and he makes me laugh
like gut laugh starting to pass out,
I'm seeing sparkles
about four times a day.
And I don't know, I don't know
anything that's better than that.
I knew Dax before you.
- That's true.
- I could have been Mrs. Dax.
We don't know.
It was never offered.
- I don't even want to
know if you guys hooked up.
- Never!
- Because I don't like,
I don't even want to ask those questions.
I wouldn't put it past either
of you, and that's fine.
You were young, you were kids,
and you were both gorgeous, it's fine.
- Wouldn't it be weird if right now
I'm like "by the way,
we dated for six months.
"On the DL."